à combien vous seriez heureux voilà vous
savez à combien vous seriez heureux
financièrement j'ai envie de vous dire
voilà parce que pour moi l'argent ne
fait pas de bonheur aussi peut-être pas
d'accord non je suis pas d'accord et
enfin évidemment que ça fait pas le
bonheur mais c'est quand même un gros
facilitateur pour tout mais même la
santé par exemple on dit oui mais tant
qu'on a pas la santé mais quand on a pas
la santé si on a pas d'argent ben c'est
beaucoup plus difficile que quand on en
a on ne l'aide pour je sais pas pour moi
je vois par exemple pour aller en EHPAD
et des trucs comme ça vous rendez pas
compte c'est beaucoup plus quand on a de
l'argent et quand on compte on peut
beaucoup plus aider les gens franchement
bien sûr donc évidemment que c'est un
facilitateur et donc je suis pas
vraiment d'accord et je pense que c'est
un peu par démagogique les gens ils
disent ouais les belles valeurs l'amitié
tout ça l'amour etc vous pouvez pas voir
l'amour avec l'argent
arrêtez de dire n'importe quoi une meuf
tu peux être le plus blindée du monde
c'est elle te kiffe pas elle te kiffe
pas de quoi
le cadre orange
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle peut faire genre où elle peut elle
aime bien
la vérité les mecs désolé le vrai amour
une meuf tu peux être le plus blindé du
monde
la jeune femme et aussi riche que vous
enfin que vous pas vous vous génériques
[Rires]
ça fait des années qu'elle travaille
elle a fait fronceuse elle chez elle je
peux te dire que c'est pas un magot qui
est là
en voiture de sport un truc tu sais pas
ce que c'est sa vie voiture de sport
age de capital sa vie
mais non mais bien sûr que non parce que
je suis désolé mes parents par exemple
étaient dans une pauvreté mais au début
vraiment crasse pendant 10 ans ils ont
jamais été aussi heureux parce qu'il
s'aimaient et vous par exemple Cyril
vous avez eu des hauts et des bas quand
vous étiez en bas ce que vous étiez
vraiment plus malheureux qu'aujourd'hui
quand j'étais en vacances le 8 mars ou
dans la vie
financièrement j'étais très content moi
mais je veux dire parce que moi en fait
moi je je voilà je m'en fous moi
par exemple si vous me faites don
de vous serez aussi heureux je suis sûr
mais tu vas mourir bientôt
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr
alors bien sûr l'absence d'argent fait
le malheur c'est comme ça qu'il faut
lire le sondage tous les gens
aujourd'hui qui crèvent la fin qui n'ont
pas l'argent qui le disent de moi non
plus rien vous rendez compte bien sûr je
trouve que c'est insultant pour eux pour
ça que j'ai répondu non c'est un sondage
qui est effectivement fait par des bobos
des gens déconnectés mais quand on a pas
d'argent on souffre on peut rien faire
on peut même plus nourrir se chauffer
donc l'argent fait le bonheur des gens
parce que quand on en a pas on ne peut
plus vivre
moi je pense que tout le monde aimerait
pouvoir vivre correctement oui
exactement voilà ah oui mais mais en
vrai que tu comme dis tu vas pas manger
de steaks
évidemment que il y a des gens
extrêmement aisés qui sont peut-être
malheureux parce que ils n'ont pas aimé
ou parce que ils ont ils ont pas de
famille autour d'eux etc qui se sentent
seuls malgré tout pardon mais vaut mieux
être riche en bonne santé et et du coup
on est heureux
le bonheur je ça me suffit moi juste
amour et amour et au fond
dans la vérité
moi je pense que tout le monde serait et
je le dis après vous allez me prendre
des ayant et c'est un démagout si tout
le monde avait pour vivre correctement
parce que tout le monde serait heureux
un moment un moment que tu vas acheter
tu vas acheter
moi je mets oui en fait il faut juste
vider ta tête si tu as de quoi manger tu
as de quoi tes enfants tu es amoureux et
tu as de quoi sortir juste de temps en
temps exactement
blindés des problèmes dans leur tête
tout seul parce que même les gens qui
sont peut-être une ils ont toujours des
problèmes ils sont tous suivis
par-dessus
il a raison il a raison il y a plein de
mecs qui sont pété de thunes qui sont
pas loin hein
vous pensez que par exemple Bernard
Arnault Jeff Bezos et son son ils sont
pas plus heureux que Raymond par exemple
moi je suis sûr que je rigole plus que
moi je suis sûr je rigole pas
je suis en galère
je pense tout le monde Bernard Arnault
les grandes et tous les grandes ce monde
il se méfie tout le monde quand
quelqu'un leur parle ils savent même pas
parler moi on parle de gens pas
forcément moi je te moi je te dis mais
simplement pouvoir être payé des jouets
à ses enfants les emmener
pas avoir de problème pour pouvoir payer
un médecin ce pays à manger et ben voilà
tu as pas besoin de ta part
on confond un peu aussi l'esbroufe voilà
les signes extérieurs
les mecs les mecs qui commencent à se
taper des tops poubelles
oui ça compte oui oui ça compte
minimum syndicale à quel moment ça
compte c'est quoi le minimum syndical
non mais c'est combien
parce qu'il a fait son banquier là
il me reste à la fin du mois
une somme c'est le fait de pas se
soucier c'est le fait de voir de pas
avoir de souci
pas le mec de Londres il est bien
il a pas trop de soucis mais tant mieux
mais il travaille pas il est très
heureux
oui pourquoi
non non mais et donc ici alors si c'est
le même mec non mais non mais si ce même
mec n'était pas bien
s'il avait pas d'oseille est-ce que tu
serais avec lui bien sûr je serai avec
lui évidemment je serai avec lui
on a des hauts des bas et cetera voilà
c'est pas ça
on se choisit pas parce qu'on a de
l'argent moi j'ai besoin d'être avec
quelqu'un qui est ambitieux voilà tu
travailles qui est ambitieux qui se
bougent les fesses je peux pas être avec
un petit peu sur le canapé non mais
c'est vrai
un but il faut être voilà mais pas
forcément donc comme il réussit dans la
vie et comme il a de l'ambition ça me
plait
ambitieux et qui est égal au final il
est quand même aura des pâquerettes 2003
je suis sortie avec un pizzaïolo donc tu
imagines bien qu'en faisant des
24 Heures
j'imagine bien quand vous en tournez les
pâtes à pizza c'était pas non plus
le champion du monde de la pizza
Giovanni
Zitouni
il y avait un pied au Maroc un peu en
Italie je trouve que l'argent rend beau
quand vous voyez par exemple l'équipe
qui ont beaucoup plus d'argent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'argent le pouvoir etc
et puis après voilà ils sont sous
contents ils sont au bras d'une top
model enfin tous les voleurs sont
toujours aussi moches hein
à côté de la voiture tu dis c'est pas
c'est quoi là
l'exemple de pionvier Bernard c'est le
meilleur exemple mais quoi
le
[Applaudissements]
le mec arrêtez le mec je faisais m'avoir
mis
blanc là
je suis en
[Applaudissements]
bordel de merde Alexandre va montre on
dirait un prof de philo
jeune comédien